uh substitutions i believe we have cut
councilor hutchings for chancellor
mcgough is that right
yep
right
item two minutes of the community and
resources meeting 6th of september
i'll go through them page by page from
the bottom
for
corrections
okay three
four
five
six
and seven
[Music]
i'm actually okay
to move second
all in favor
ah
one number so that one's abstaining i
assume thank you
any comments on any of them
no
proper job
so we move on to action list
page eight
okay christy happy with the first one
i don't think i've had a response it
does say to be sent to me i haven't had
it
i mean it was a general question about
uh could members be advised when there
was an offset it wasn't a specific
okay it was in respect of a particular
um planning application at the time i
think that's what he was being looked
into with cancer christie is talking
more generally then
be an expectation
yeah i knew about it okay so i didn't
need responses just it could counsel it
be advised when there is an offset
because
it did come as a surprise that the
offset was in the whole war
right
item for public contributions i've not
been told of any
item 5 forward plan page 10.
you've seen it
any comments to it
i noticed a couple of things have slept
but there we are that life i suppose
no comment
proper job
uh
item six declarations of interest you
don't need to be told i don't think
item seven agreement of the agenda
between parts one and two
parts from part two suggested
clearly obvious business
and i have a proposal council a lot
seconded by
councillor james
all in favor that we're going to part
two for those items that's unanimous
thank you
now we run on item 8 urgent matters of
information i have none
nope all quiet on the western front
item nine community council of community
grant scheme pages 11 to 14 understand
yeah uh thanks thanks chair um very
short report i'm sure members will be
aware that the annual councillor
community grant schedule closes in july
of each year
um so as i'd see the end of july this
year there's a balance of 22
170 pounds left to be seen
um and
primarily the recommendation is to
utilize that balance by sharing it or
distributing it
between each of the 36 environments
therefore providing an additional
allocation for this current financial
year 21 22 of 615 and very very
straightforward i had a report that's a
recommendation but members may wish to
consider um
terms on the laws
proposing it
[Music]
every time somebody approaches me i have
to come to torridge and ask how i'm
trying
i don't keep a running total of it and
we also get people i don't know if it's
happened to other people
people approach you you say yes you know
you can have 250 pounds and they leave
it for about three months and then
you've forgotten all about it by the
time they get they get around to doing
paperwork
could they can we all be emailing this
people
coupled with that i'd like to be emailed
just before the closing date
because i have a habit of saying to
people
get in touch with me near the end of the
financial year and i know what i'm
looking like how much you can have
and then i've gone over the closing date
and they get more
so i'd like a warning
a month before the closing date to say
your pot still got excellent
gentlemen yeah i mean the trouble is
with the grams um we can't give them a
grant and um
what what rather if their fines our
bench they cannot buy the bench out of
their own funds and then we give them
the grant because if they could we could
turn around and say well you've already
bought it you're going to fall at no
ground so in the backward process in my
opinion i think we ought to be allowed
to give it
when they apply for it rather than when
their work is completed
um
i probably loved it
any other comment i get councillor
hudson well i've always have found in
the last 12 months uh vicki feather at
ttvs really really helpful
um you know she responds immediately to
emails
um she invariably answers her phone
which is a joy
and she has been very informative about
how much spender
i understand the difficulties of people
asking you for grants but they do have
to provide some kind of evidence
about we're paying it to a um i know we
know individuals but whose bank account
it's going into
how it's going to be paid so i think we
need some checks and balances before we
hand it over
um and i would just urge you all to uh
you know check we know what the dates
are about
when our spending power comes to an end
to to contact jackie and vicki feather
because she has been i don't know she's
going to be continuing to do it next
year uh through the chair um but if she
is i you know as an officer she is very
diligent
christie did you want to speak again yes
sir
can i answer all a hallucination on the
point of raise there about
we only give money after that spend it i
i thought i gave money beforehand
we don't ask to see receipts or invoices
do well
[Music]
there's a process to make sure
everything is above board and in order
bank accounts document any documentation
required etc obviously what we don't
want to be doing is playing it right out
at the outset and then having to to
recover it from different groups
organizations who need to have certainty
that the
work or whatever's being done is going
ahead
um i guess additionally um
hudson and yes we envisage uh north
devon plus and he continuing
to see the foreseeable future
anyway so that's a
system that has been working
in terms of the
providing more information yes i don't
see why not
why we could produce a monthly update
um that advises members how much has
been spent and then chairs as you
mentioned something uh prior to the end
of the scheme so members still got an
opportunity to allocate any unspent
resources
council the laws yeah i mean they're
filling the form to get the grant if you
give them the money first after the
month fill in the form so i think the
system is good
but i totally accept and support the
comments about more information
but in the systems but it works
okay we're happy to move on
all those in favor of adopting
that's
unanimous item 10 section 106 grant
funding application aim lane park
westwood oh
an old saga comes back again
who's taking this one
chair i'll take it take it again uh i
won't mention any of the old saga um
we've had a
long debate as you know um so this is in
respect of the
avon lane park if westwood polish
members undoubtedly will be aware of
um that scheme is progressing with the
within the town council and we've since
received a request for an application
for the allocation of some section 106
grant funding
the grant funding is shown on the table
on page 15
and the request is for the the entire
total of those sums
um chair the recommendation is that the
funding agreement uh be entered into
with
northern town council the release of
those resources and that's on page 17 to
share very straightforward reports
councillor bushby
moved councillor james seconded
councillor harley thank you this is a
great question actually
on the three on page 15
one says play provisional area of site
and the third one says recreation and
the vicinity of the site
what distances do we look at between and
we'll talk just about this one i'll talk
about in general
what's class there's the vicinity of the
site is there a distance involved or is
it you know from one side of the town to
another or what i don't know
i believe it could be variable
dependence on uh what's agreed at the
timing of the agreement of the the
section 106 so i guess in some instances
it may
stipulate a specific
um my age or circumference um in others
it's left uh relatively
generalized as is the case with this one
as well
so it's a bit woolly then
in this instance yes
um but
um the park is within the vicinity of
uh those that development
okay thank you
kendall look yeah i just
just as a point of clarity the section
106 moneys uh when we were entering
negotiations from northern town council
to torres district council
formed as recommended by torrid part of
the business term
going forward for how we were going to
raise the funds to actually
complete the renovation and remodeling
of the farm so yes they were very much
aware and there is more money in the
pipeline in the westwood area when
uh the build is uh bills are completed
but this was very much identified
and has approved within our business
plan
what was were the four wins and land of
beverly age gardens aware that there
were still somethings available to them
um
so it seems straight you know
have a private conversation about this
the the three um bills but that was
their section 106 contribution towards
recreation
when they completed their bill
so they would have been aware that when
they signed their section 106 agreement
as part of their planning consent
that these monies were allocated for
recreational purposes
general laws
so it seems logical to me that it's fine
to uh use the money in that way
um
we're trying to lift
westbrook
and in saying that i would like to
extend an invitation for all the
councils here become the west wing
on saturday the 6th of november when the
children themselves will be opening them
probably when the 106's were agreed
there were small amounts and when we
allocated the recreation the question
without going down through the planning
was whether they were allocated
specifically or in general
but you know we're talking eight years
ago on the applications um in one case
and five years ago on the other end
so i think you know
it is a substantial part in the middle
of appledorm but
is there a current up-to-date list of
section 106 money that has come in
is it available by ward
[Music]
we used to get one
um or we i did ask one at the asset
management we had a very long it was
quite astonishing how much there was
actually it was in millions i know
okay okay
laws
this 106 lead comes up and up again when
a major planning application or a
planning application that will involve
106 money comes up
surely the ward members should be spoken
to at that time
and
help in the selection programs
as i recall it has been agreed that they
should be but having said that i am not
convinced that they are
we can send a reminder i think
i guess the other things about the these
particular ones because james alluded to
the first one was eight years ago would
have been in a in a previous council and
the other two were five years ago so
different ford members may have been
consulted that's that's the difficulty
and that's probably you know
what comes to christie referred to
having an up-to-date list is then useful
for the new amendment so
um
the action list and
will do councillor james um what as i
understand talking to uh the planning
manager
is that
i know there are this uh whether we're
up to date i'm not 100 sure
but his intention is to ensure that
board members are informed we are going
through or we've just gone through a
process of selecting a new 106
a strategic officer in that department
it will take us a little while to get
that
working smoothly um but it is the
intention that board members will be
kept up to date and there will be an
up-to-date list of
um as the 106 money is
agreed
it's the sort of thing that could come
through our members bulletin except that
my members bulletin this week was
showing minecraft saying it's too big
you'll damage your computer downloading
i did get it down but um
i just pointed out we need to be careful
what goes on members bulletin when we're
getting warnings like that coming with
it counselor lock um
yeah i mean from my point of view i've
always been kept involved by planning
officers about one of
you know by the time you pay for the
safety services
so yeah
right can we move on
um
item 11 funding requests from the plan
approached the council in february 2020
i mentioned they have some financial
difficulties i won't go through all the
various financial difficulties but one
of the things was they've come they've
got a little bit dependent on
non-recurrent grants in various streams
and actually
funded
supporting their current operations
in march 2020 this was just before the
pandemic and the lockdown seen i agreed
to support
the plan and asked officers to work with
that to understand their finances which
i did with at the time a lady called
francis lloyd who was the finance
manager at the plow
um september 2020 this committee
authorized twenty twenty five thousand
pounds of funding to support the plow
in between of course the lockdown
happened and the plow at that time was
closed
and i was tasked to then
report back to this committee a year
later september 2020 to see how the fire
was going on obviously of course a lot
now carried on right for some
considerable time
also since then there's been quite a
change in uh staff at the lot and the
flower francis lloyd he was the finance
that we replaced by somebody called
trina
and the previous chairman stood down
so we've connected again with the plan
to understand their financial positions
and it's all detailed in the report but
the simple truth is
they've been closed they've received
significance amounts of business support
grants from ourselves from north devon
council respectively hans and also from
the arts council
and actually they have significant funds
now in their backer they're don't
immediate threats of closure for the
plow
um
[Music]
and i said detailed but look 213 000
pounds in what got unrestricted funds so
that's money in the bank no
name or no task attacker they would also
have someone in the back which is
restricted fund means it's related to
grant funds they've received and they're
obliged to spend the money
in accordance with those original grant
applications
um in conversations with the clown
uh they've transmissioned some business
plans to look forward they're not
expected to be completed for december of
this year perhaps january of next year
and at the time of writing this report
and as of today still not had a copy of
that account for 2012-21
so really in summary it's a case of
there's no immediate danger to the plow
ceasing to trade which was the case it
appeared back in february 2020
financially at least covered has been of
benefit to the plan
and
not only just really reopened
a range of
events on and the recommendation is that
we
come back and look at the plow again
when the council's actually got more
information and that's when the plows
got more information when they've
actually been trained for a while you
know
the new kind of income levels it can do
and also when they've actually got a
business plan that we can review
also december january gives us time in
terms of actually know where the
council's finances will be in terms of
the spending review and what our
finances will be at that time so the
recommendation is
thankfully the cloud has come through
the pandemic in a healthy financial
position
and we'll review at a later date when
more information is not bought by them
and by ourselves
i'm happy to take any questions
counselor hudson i think it's a very
straightforward decision for us this
morning i'd like to move the
recommendations through the secondary
proposed and seconded
that we put it off for the time being
look at the later date in effect
all in favor
that's unanimous
we can move on
uh
harbor board
we've got the minutes of the harbour
board here
[Music]
i trust you've read them
i can't confirm
as i did to the harbour board the
councilor james and i had a fascinating
trip on the pilot boat
when the last big boat went out of
biddeford we went out on the pilot boat
um
to see the pilot hop off the big boat
onto the pilot boat is a job i would not
want to undertake it with a beautiful
sunny still evening when we did it
i wouldn't want to do it in a
and having said that the two chaps who
drive the pilot boat
i wouldn't want to do it for their wages
of their hours of the day and night
so we've got some very impressive staff
out there
working um
the harbor minutes speak for themselves
right any comment or wish chancellor
laws just just a question here
the boat itself is
my understanding is not at that stage
it's in for repair in apple door
shipyard somewhere down there at the
moment going through it survey
they're hopeful it'll go through with
not too much trouble
but it is getting older and like all of
us when we get older things do go wrong
cancer teams
i don't know i agree with that um
it's a lovely evening on a
very still day in the discussions with
the pilot you know they've already
looked up what would be a substitute
though and apparently you you can get
second-hand life of uh vote a reasonable
price um and the one thing that folk is
restricted on is a it's only got a
single engine so if it breaks down
they've got no other power then secondly
it can only do i can't remember what the
speed was
we were nearly doing the speed the most
it could do to keep in front of the big
boat so it will be a an item on an
agenda at some stage depending on what
the report comes back but it could be a
good nick but it is still only a single
engine and it is still
um
probably at the maximum power it can
generate in terms of speed
so it may be an issue another day
okay
thank you um
again nothing
i did actually receive a telephone call
from someone yesterday um talking about
the repairs that are going to be needed
on pilot vote and the figure that they
mentioned to me i've got no evidence to
support that but it was substantially
more than the six thousand pound that's
uh on the report here um so
i didn't ask you to check who the
appropriate officer is to speak with us
i just want some further information as
to what the condition of the boat is and
what the likely cost of the repairs are
whether the phone call that i had was
anything like accurate or whether i can
leave the figure that's the phone
steve i'm chair of sean kearney and
richard haste went down
last week
to look and have a discussion
with the the repairers i haven't got an
exact figure so i don't want to
mention that i figured out but we can
circulate that
to members um i understand it isn't a
position that's repairable this time but
um again as fantastically as uh sean to
have a look at what the costs of a
replacement might be because as you said
all the time costs of repairs long term
amount but sometimes it's more
economical to
procure something new so it's making
sure we get that balance at the right
time that's exactly the point
but it's something we've got to have
simple
counselor lock
catch the harley
thank you
i know she's surprisingly only two
counsellors present at that meeting can
you speak up over i noticed quite
surprisingly there's only two
councillors present at that meeting
it seems a a low number but moving on
from that i notice it's an interim
harbour manner harbour and yeah
is that what happened to the other other
master
the other harbor master unfortunately
has a serious illness and has had to
pull out
uh
yeah paul labster was a good man getting
on top of it he's had to pull out
um
i think it's fair to say we're working
on a replacement harbor master
they're not easy to come by and they're
not cheap
and we're looking externally and
internally
time will tell
but it is in hand i can assure you
just me i'm sorry to hear that but
always early isn't it man nice to get on
there sorry
laws i'm sorry to come back
the situation is
this is like having an old car
standing out
500 quid having it serviced
to find it breaks down
[Music]
and then you've got the double expense
and we'd be assured that they won't
undertake the repairs until we've got
price
um because
we want to avoid that situation of a
double payout
thank you chair
okay steve um
i think the repairs may already be being
carried out so
um i don't i don't believe there will be
an opportunity to produce a report back
to committee for committee consider
that in time otherwise we will be left
without a boat in them
but i think we should keep apple door
cancellers happy with the fact that
we're keeping all things going rather
than caught in carbon problems we're
making new ones
councillor pride
it's not uncommon practice to um repair
a vessel and then sell it to someone
else but we then build a new one just as
an idea because that's what commonly
happens with military services is that
they'll build a new one and then they'll
sell their old one to someone else you
can't afford to build a brand new one so
just as an idea i think that's what we
could do
well
we may well come to it we'll have to
start budgeting i think
no one else wishing to speak on the
harbour report oh chancellor kristin
yeah see i'll refer to the top page 67
about these ledgers
um
i did go down and uh i collected them
actually they've gone to the record
office where they're being kept under
climate control conditions they're with
the rest of the bittersweet harbour
records actually
and they're not 150 years old they they
weren't that old actually the ledgers
were but what the
information is
but they are interesting
well we've asked that you be given the
opportunity to review them which you
clearly have
and to advise them i suppose what we do
with them
where they should go
should they be destroyed which didn't
seem right to us
now they've gone to the record office in
boston
thank you peter
and he also in the harbor
property
right i think we move into part two can
we have a vote with the part two please
all in favor
we were proposing second second agreed
earlier